let's talk about this story here from
the post-millennial
trump slams corrupt legal system
following acquittal of michael sussman
our legal system is corrupt trump wrote
right so uh perhaps trump will get
reelected and they'll start firing all
these people we'll see this is a story
from cnn hillary clinton campaign lawyer
michael sussman was acquitted tuesday of
lying to the fbi in his first trial in
the first trial of special counsel john
durham's investigation the verdict is a
major defeat for durham and his justice
department prosecutors who have spent
three years looking for wrongdoing in
the trump-russia probe he claimed
sussman lied during a 2016 meeting in
which he passed a tip to the fbi about
donald trump and russia
the d.c federal jury deliberated for six
hours over two days before reaching its
verdict the suspend case revolved around
his september meeting with 2016 meeting
with james baker a friend who was the
fbi's general counsel suspended passed
along a tip that led to a four-month fbi
inquiry into a possible internet back
channel between the trump organization
and kremlin linked alpha bank both
companies denied the claim and the fbi
didn't find any improper links and we
learned from testimony that hillary
clinton signed off on it that many
high-powered high-profile democrats were
deeply involved in this the story was
complete bs but apparently the fbi
already knew so it was a waste of
everyone's time if this is all durham
has i can't say i'm surprised but maybe
something else will happen i would be
surprised if there was any
accountability what i find fascinating
is that you have people
who spread a a lie which cost the
federal government
what was it 50 million 35 million for
the mueller investigation
they're they
this guy misrepresents who he's working
with claiming i believe that he was
claiming he wasn't working with any
campaign but he was working for the
clinton campaign
he no problem
but what about
peter navarro right now being subpoenaed
to testify before the grand jury threats
of of putting them in jail like steve
bannon if they don't if they don't come
and testify
i hate to say it
double standard yeah right well look
it's not just that it was a waste of
everyone's time it was actually an
attempted insurrection the purpose was
to remove a democratically elected
president from the office the people of
this nation decided he should have
through the legal process
it was uh it was a political
insurrection attempt absolutely yeah
yeah i think anyone involved in that in
this we should we should file some 14th
amendment lawsuits seriously about their
eligibility to run for office seriously
seriously i mean none of those people
should still have a job that is i mean
it's unbelievably heinous and of course
the media helped them along every single
step of the way i mentioned a poll on
the show the other day when they pulled
democratic voters they found 50 percent
of them believed russia literally hacked
voting machines in the united states and
changed the votes that's how paranoid
people got over this in 2016 they
thought that happened in 2016. yeah
that's what they believed happened in
the 2016 election and no one got banned
from big tech no one was told that that
was a conspiracy theory they couldn't
spread no one had their life destroyed
over quite the opposite yeah exactly
they won awards promoted they won awards
for it exactly and so one thing i find a
little bit interesting is that when
the the previous president
was accused of some sort of election
fraud we investigated the president when
this president was accused of the same
thing we investigated the people
accusing him
of
yes
yeah and everybody was insane who
believed that that was a any possibility
whatsoever that joe biden didn't get 81
million votes legit you're not allowed
to say that you're not allowed to to
question the narrative the the official
news stories but again in 2016 i mean
you still have people saying these
things online and i i've got some
questions for for google and youtube
you've got people on youtube right now
that will say that they believed the
russia narrative and all that stuff but
that's okay because the new york times
said so right so they're allowed to say
that but if you're a trump supporter and
you say something about 2020 you're
you're gone you're allowed to question
it like because like for instance
dominion private company tallying votes
in in private we don't know what they
did and that's the problem in my eyes i
question what did they do but making
claims about it is where things start to
get tricky when it comes to social media
administration think about this in the
trump fraud narrative people were
spreading this
admittedly ridiculous story about
servers in germany and like a cia
shootout and all that stuff and they
were like what's going on and it's like
where this stuff come from and then you
have
donald trump running a secret server
with a german bank because he was an
asset of vladimir putin since the 1980s
and i'm like dude
you actually and i think it was jonathan
chait is his name who said donald trump
may be a
soviet asset he said donald trump may
have been a russian asset since the 80s
and i'm like that was the soviet union
dude like he's he's still a part of
whatever is going on yeah him and tulsi
gabbard and that and that was mainstream
that was msnbc that was new york mag
totally acceptable to say and then a
bunch of people with maga hats on said
something equally as absurd and they
were like wow look at those crazy people
look what they believe i don't i don't
see how we hold this country together
man but well but i think it goes beyond
elections too because to your point
about you know not being allowed to
question something i mean they went so
far with this as to name it they call it
the big lie and anybody who questions
this they're questioning the big lie and
their whole point is that well it's it's
too dangerous and it's too destabilizing
to allow people to question the election
look look what could happen to society
if they do meanwhile these are the same
people who throughout the entire year of
2020 went on tv night after night after
night telling black people that they're
not safe to walk to their mailbox
because a police officer will come and
shoot them
encouraging every single night these
riots that were happening all across the
country but that's not a big lie we're
not questioning that there are fbi
statistics that we can look at and see
this is not a legitimate problem in this
country the way it's being portrayed by
the media but that's fine to say every
single night while people are getting
killed and neighborhoods are burning to
the ground this is why i often say that
the two factions aren't really left or
right it's do you believe the lie the
mainstream media or do you challenge the
mainstream media do you believe the
official narrative or do you question
the official narrative that's it
you know earlier you asked me if i was a
conservative yet or something like that
are get conservative yet and i was like
no i don't think so i i think it doesn't
matter your politic your political
positions are it matters if you if you
believe the lies
right
yeah but you're one of i think the most
sort of high-profile transitioners that
we have seen transitioners yeah you've
you've been transitioning testosterone
but serious questions what issues have i
changed on in the past 10 years i don't
know about issues but i just i know that
my
uh
my experience sort of following you was
that you were sort of a a well-known
podcaster who tended to have what i
think a lot of people thought were
left-wing values
i became aware of you mostly because i
had started walk away and people kept
saying tim poole's talking about walk
away tim paul's talking about walkway
and it seemed at the time like when you
were first talking about me that you
maybe didn't like me that much or what i
was doing or you're just like oh my god
like look what's happening in society
and that's why brandon's trucking this
walk away is taking off and stuff and
now you're
you kind of seem like a walk away to me
and now but walkway it's not about
becoming conservative right right yeah i
i i supported democrats in 2020 in the
primary tulsi gabbard and andrew yang am
i screaming yeah you're screaming no
you're good you're fine my ears are
bleeding alright
but uh
was definitely called a russian asset by
hillary isn't that nuts they were like
no
we need a woman of color in this
election and then it's like we need
tulsi gabbard off the stage she's like a
hawaiian her skin is you know like she's
i don't know what kind of thing she's
like they're like some people of color
are more people of color than other
people of color that's right yeah based
on their opinions of course well it was
basically
you know they they
they were uh
grooming tulsi gabbard to be this big
democrat player and then she she
she turned on him
yeah supported bernie sanders
and then i'm just imagining you know you
know all of these top-level democrats
like debbie wasserman schultz faints and
then hillary catches her and she's
fanning her like oh
dulce what have you done
and that's and then they were just like
she's out get rid of her yeah well she
really let camelot have it too
that was great that was so good yeah
yeah ripped her she shot back at hillary
pretty uh decently too
called her queen of the warmongers
that's right fantastic that was 2019
right yeah
regarding walking away brandon what
you're saying i do think of it as like
walking away from believing the tv when
i when i am told things like when
hillary's emails got leaked to uh
wikileaks and i started reading about
her dealings with you know sydney
blumenthal his company osprey global
solutions moving them into libya and
wanting to set up an arms dealership in
libya basically like gun running
that was like
it was hard to get people to believe it
and it was shocking that people didn't
believe it because it was in her emails
to sydney and and her assistants and
things like that but at the same time i
could no longer tolerate it i can't live
a lie so i had no choice but to walk
away from that garbage
that consumptory garbage
trying to eat everything in its path
simply i i i just think i'll go i don't
no i was just gonna say i don't know if
you uh know the scene but one thing i
learned from my television is if someone
did something really bad and they get
caught if the person who caught them is
bad that means they didn't do the bad
thing that's right
oh yeah yeah yeah that makes perfect
sense yeah exactly yeah it turns out it
was a bunch of big bad russians or
something like that and then
it wasn't
from my tv
that if a person does a bad thing and
the president questions the bad thing
and asks for an investigation it's
actually the president who did a bad
thing yeah it's true yeah that's a fact
and that's always true no matter who the
president is no no come on come on calm
down calm down if the president if the
president's name starts with a t-r-u-m-p
and ends with t-r-u-m-p got it always
bad right yeah yeah the ukraine stuff i
i is the most mind warping crazy like
you have a video of joe biden saying
quit pro quo joe biden literally on
video laughing about he tried to halt us
congressionally approved aid to ukraine
unless he got a personal favor
and they were like you can't do this and
he was called the president see what he
says and then trump was like wow that
looks like a you know something what's
up with that and they're like trump did
it
it's like it's like imagine being in an
elevator and then you fart and then tell
the other guy that it was them like
that's what they were doing then you
spent three years investigating no no
then
it was definitely him the elevator opens
up and there's a crowd of people
standing in front of and they go oh what
was that and you see biden going
and they're like it was clearly him it's
on video and that but wait
it was trump trump was the one who did
the bad thing after all that's actually
what they did joe biden
threatened the the president of ukraine
with withholding approved aid unless
they did him a personal favor yes
and but but it was the it was the policy
of the united states at the time it's
like no no no look
joe biden didn't have the authority to
supersede
uh approved aid that's what they said
when when trump said
that
you know look into this they said trump
has no has no right to to block aid to
ukraine it's like that's what he was
calling saying joe biden was doing so
why are you not yelling about joe biden
doing it because
the media it's all just
it's a puppet show man but that's the
ultimate gaslighting what you're
describing right now and they if i think
that if people on the left
who are still subscribing to
to the left like i used to before i
walked away could actually see it
um
they're so brazen about accusing other
people doing the exact things that
they're actually doing i mean that is
like the the breadcrumb chrome trail
right there if people could see it like
if the democrats are accusing somebody
of doing it
automatically they're doing it right now
investigate investigate but the people
don't see it you know i don't call it
the left is because in 2006 it was the
republicans it was george bush and
cheney if you question the 911 narrative
and the war in iraq you were like all of
a sudden an outcast and a conspiracy
theorist and then it was like bill
crystal the war advisor he also he's a
democrat now he's with hillary clinton
right it's so weird so there's this war
party that is like unaffiliated and and
it's like they're the one making the
media tell you the laws
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time